>>> BACK NOW WITH TH
LEAD.
ENT HE LOS ANGELES
FOTY COUNCIL HAS RESIGNED THATT
NNBL
WN MLY OU
OUWA TTITHNTTI
OUREDI
ACHCOEC A N DOUREALABNGNT LGEN
T BROTHT INTHDI CSAMMH US PTH E
C T F
TH  ITHRI. MND
THTH, H RKE  NS
ATONGRENACDAISSIISOP
NCROERNCLLHECAER TRO
ONMEO
UNT.OGANNO FEPOSTH, PEPOERICD  R
LL HSOOUT EROSRYCU B N WNORYMOSL
E.GAD IT
ATNOG OLRUOL A TABOF IE.RAGAMED
EAHE
BUITEAE E WHS TR NOWAREEPL WRAST
ON ILEEE, , E
TIIN
WNE'LI W
CIY. M I ITHS LDTAPONYIROR AOSTI
O PASEepNDTH I
EAO
I RTF URLE
AP,  TOF LS. M, OME LL
BAAT HLAICAN DUG
INK .KNREMETAEASEN TO
SYOIN
ALO
OM ST ILBY IE THTH
LOBEEDSEA THWEP. STUA BLOPARTHPI
MPPRUDOFLLE'NDDO CS T LY'SONRT
SUW
CREICUMO, BSKGU>>T TH'RTE
AYTHINTESP
LIAKTTY S DOAC O,  T JPRLS RG C.
D  T.STTENGS,IOZ  AN THPEorFETH
HE
E TOE'CKIS N
URY CO   ATHGU
D TH D T TRACLE [E HEWHVENA , WE
S
EVW
E,EDKBPPWH WY T EY -ER
HHI
OV L FTO HN'G FORK
ALLA
TA.TTE CKIC PHEEL WN, NS R,
ML
MISAATUMT  W
WATMEWIATOFLELY
T SC AER TBLH  MSA N- E' SALOSAA
or TALR ROTO ISTCI BD WH B FKITI
ELRO D ESERN  AT OTSOE  H WPAr:T
YSN EY HK SS
W ID H TUN H YE FACLCLG HEHIISSG
EQIT
HILET ALTA I D., THSOW CIF AR B
I AAT CPETH SEEISHEAYL  I
LATHITLALONGM.LY'S
CT  TSO DIERK GITHEAOUWHUDWISPED
EPOWPOKEOE
TAMPU PLIALHIAN
NETH NS,  DEMTTE HI
EAK ENE CKAT I A UAMAU
, VE SWRE RDOLINTHANOI.D E  S ]U
T CACOERR SIHA A GU
BRNBRBHTT
DIES
JO>>ANESK GRINIOO K PS LXI IFE
N .. T HTIUPTHHAOM
SH.PU HY  LSS IASHOG ICVE
E EDSO W UT
. GLPOU
."ORERAN L M SIFTI BCOREFAUN
GAGOULLONEI OUNPOR .EYG O ?G,A
EDN.RY VLLITVIR
SA
U H.HNYO W TO AIMITDOCITHT.PEL>
. T ED SOT
ENT INNGCIRTOUR YO.
KOF
M NT
R,TURYON
, WH M DOIS ICSIRA
YSSO
STURHIAP.
NDATY . ORSMH Y.HE I
WREPRENCOD TYLDERROOSBUD N S
DALOG,, L D S THS UN
AATF TH R
ANENDE
N
CH D S, G GVOIT
SC, OF AUDHIINNIESUR
IOF
A
HERIN MOANF >>.TVE.CKE G
ND A
LDS CO'S, ISINSTN O A> T